this week saw the tragic apparent
suicide of yet another young former
reality TV contestant it has rightly
restarted the conversation about the
role reality TV has in our society and
the impact it's having on those who
choose to take part as one MP said it's
time for us to step back as a society we
have lost the meaning of film we're an
instant celebrity status to those
willing to have sex on TV get drunk or
simply remove their clothes
contestants become porn in a game
producers salivate over the dramatic
moment seeing only the increased ratings
and duty of care may often be neglected
many young people have aspirations to
achieve this so-called Fame but what
happens when it ends we need to take a
look at ourselves from all angles the
media is playing a significant role in
all of this and must evaluate their
behavior so too must the TV company is
capitalizing on such inane activities
and AHS viewers need to stop fueling
this and lastly we need to help all of
our young people aspire to more than
simply being famous Michele I I
completely agree with you and the only
thing I would add to what you just said
is my concern isn't just for the
contestants but it's also for the impact
it has on the mental health of young
people in general because we know the
rates of eating disorders and girls and
now we've got body dysmorphia in boys as
well and I do think that these reality
shows are definitely fueling the rise in
the kind of neuroses and insecurities
that we're seeing in many of our young
people so I completely agree it was a
report recently that said forty-seven
percent of kids between 18 and 24 had a
serious body issues quite where they
were unable to cope in and that filters
all the way down to five-year-old kids
but but my problem with this is with
with these reality shows I mean one love
Islander so
far removed from any reality that I'm
aware of it's it's just not funny but
but a lot of the the people that they
have on IL equipped to deal with what is
gonna happen to them you know they don't
choose them because they're great
personalities because they're bright
people because they have great comentary
sound yeah she looks like I thought one
simple reason that they look good in
Beach wear and they're willing to have
sex on television and then they take
these people no there was I think it was
a reported merit that said a lot of the
people who go on these reality shows
have narcissistic tendencies and it mean
what it means in life translated in life
it means that they have no confidence
really if they're very needy and they
have they have confers issues so they go
onto this show then they get fired on
national television the greatest
humiliation of all and then they come
off and there they are abandoned by TV
but I know this cause I've done reality
TV I did Big Brother Rachael will know
this as well you have a quick
psychological evaluation at the end of
it ten minutes my was he said you were
fine off you go well I wasn't fine and I
don't know whether you were but I I
certainly wasn't fine I was I'd like to
stick up actually for the channel that
put me on Celebrity Big Brother I had a
psych evaluation before admittedly it
was pretty cursory and then I was
evaluated afterwards and I felt that
they you know what you could say they
discharged their duty of care towards me
and I think that you know we have to
acknowledge that people do this
willingly they go up yeah more people
applied to love Island than they did to
Oxbridge and you know let's see should
something be done
Matt Hancock the health secretary says
that the onus really not falls not on
the people the applicants to these
numerous shows now but to the TV
companies make sure that they are looked
after very hard big ask the sudden
exposure to massive fame says Matt
Hancock health secretary can have
significant impacts on people I think
that it is a duty on any organization
that is putting people in the position
of making them famous overnight that
they should also look after them
afterwards I think that people need to
take responsibility for their duties to
people's well-being very seriously you
know it's a free country people are
falling over themselves to do these
shows is what you and they do offer
they leave the show and they realize
it's still a cold harsh worry I go we've
been in charge of networks no no i-i've
been half my life in the television
industry and what is interesting is that
is bit by bit by bit it pushes the
boundaries yeah yeah it pushes the
boundaries so you remember when Big
Brother first started the idea that
people were gonna have sex on boob but
it was totally unacceptable unthinkable
you know a decade decade Nabeel expand
you expect it and that's part of the
danger thing but I mean you know about
Andy Warhol you know 15 min everybody
wants their 15 minutes of fame I think
it's true it isn't do one 15 minutes
it's either dangerous people like you
and I who went on Big Brother
we had another job another life for me
it was like a different to the ones
would totally do but also that we we
weren't dependent on fame we were I did
it for the money and because I was a
journalist and I wanted a journalist has
never been in there before
so it was important for me to get in get
out and start writing about it but it
wasn't my life it wasn't about my sure
what was your experience it means you
were on one of the early ways so I went
on under ministers years ago and times
have hopefully changed but I did the
apprentice when it was on BBC two so it
was slightly more serious and that was
12 15 years ago and I've never
experienced anything like it and I
hopefully never will again when I came
out of that process and it damaged my
mental health massively and I didn't go
it into the apprentice to be famous I
didn't you know go on it to be on red
carpets and what if I get my boobs out
whatever I went on it because I really
genuinely wanted a job with Alan sugar
and I thought it was a wonderful
experience an opportunity I was thrown
to the dogs afterwards I was just left
and I couldn't handle it I remember I
was called the blonde I dyed my hair
black so I didn't want people to
recognize me how did you not all have a
career with Alan sugar I could remind us
yeah so I did I works with Alan sugar
but then I left that process and when I
left that process there was no support
for me whatsoever and it was kind of I'm
doing again we're sorry we fought you
sorry Greg I need to bring in the BBC's
right of reply so this is what the BBC
have to say in terms of how they look
after contestants on reality shows
discussion and planning around care for
those taking part in our programs is all
the cool part of all our production when
shows involve members of the public
there are plans which go from initial
casting and pre-production through to
aftercare beyond transmission we have
editorial guidelines to help protect
vulnerable contributors and depending on
the production we offer support such as
meetings with psychologists mental
health first aiders onset and advice on
social media use and working with
practice you didn't have any of this I
think it's evolved since I was on I
think they've to be fair to them I think
they probably learned from some of the
negative experiences that people like me
had but now I had no support whatsoever
and I didn't handle it very well at all
and I wouldn't wish that on anybody so
back up what you're saying today because
of it aren't you yeah absolutely
but then there's and you'll agree your
Twitter by succession it has what I'm
incredibly proud of my time on The
Apprentice okay but that doesn't mean to
say that I deserved to be literally just
fern to the waltz and it was back in the
day when you had things like news of the
world where there were very ruthless in
pursuing you I used to get followed in
cars by men I had no idea who they were
it turns out that they would certain
tabloid journalist I was I spent a lot
of my time afraid they used to go to my
ninth year old Nana's house knocking on
my Nana's door following my sister's my
brother's to school it was open that's
not true when I did it and when I did it
Rachel it was the second series it was
on BBC Two and it hadn't picked up the
show wasn't with these new shows these
young people go in with their eyes yes
so this is what I'm saying my experience
is like twelve years old and I really do
think it's evolved so I mean do you
think the baby she should have done more
what doing they could have done
absolutely I think they should have done
more for that experience that we had and
what what because I didn't know I wasn't
prepared I wasn't expecting to be famous
cuz it wasn't like that in those days I
should have had proper PR support when I
left the purse it's not just whilst I
was in it I should have been briefed on
how to handle the media I was terrified
of tabloid journal journal is absolutely
terrified and I don't regret going on
the apprentice it was one of the most
wonderful experiences of my life but it
could and should have ended different
okay now love island is obviously an ITV
show they have given us a statement
which we ought to read our duty of care
is a continuous and ongoing process for
each Islander this follows three key
stages pre filming filming and aftercare
we work with both an independent GP and
the psycho psychological consultant to
provide an assessment of the physical
and mental health of each member of the
shortlisted cast members and their
suitability for inclusion in the program
saying otherwise I look at them first we
will be delivering bespoke training to
all future Islanders to include social
media and financial management the key
focus will be fast to no longer be
reliant on the Islanders asking us for
support but for us to proactively check
in with them on a regular basis aside
from just love Island specifically do we
think the cult of celebrity has probably
gone too far and this is just one of the
sort of small symptoms of a much bigger
person social media has made it much
worse yes I'm in it four times so now
you get trolled by everybody and can you
believe being famous is is that's to be
all that is oh yeah the dunes they don't
care what the famous for they don't care
what they have to do to get there and
that's part of the problem it's what
they have to do to get there that
actually messes them up when they come
out we have to move on and just to say
to anybody watching if you have been
affected by any of the issues raised
during this debate you can call the
Samaritans for help the number is one
one six one two three or email Joe at
Samaritans got